COREY GOLDFEDER: Hello, and
welcome to "Use What You Know,
Building Web Apps and Services
with Google Apps Script." My
name's Corey Goldfeder.
I'm a software engineer on
Google Apps Script, and I'll
be your host today.
So before we begin, this session
has a little bit of an
audience participation
interactive section.
So if you have a laptop, tablet,
smartphone-- which
should be everyone, except
for Googlers--
please pull it out.
And you'll have a chance to use
it, assuming you can get
on the Wi-Fi.
OK.
So use what you know.
You already know
a lot of stuff.
You're sitting in this room.
You're at a Google developer
conference.
You probably know a few things
like HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript, and JSON,
RSS, XML.
DML These are not new words
to you, certainly.
And what you don't know is how
to use this stuff in Google
Apps Script.
And you also don't know why
there is a dog, a napping dog,
on my slide.
So I want to solve the easy
mystery first, which is I
really like dogs.
But we're going to go
to the harder one.
That's going to take
a full session.
So settle in.
OK.
So a brief history of
Google Apps Script.
The ghosts of I/O past, things
we've launched, particularly
in reference to user
interfaces.
So let me give a history of
where Apps Script came from.
We started off embedding
inside of Google Apps,
spreadsheets and sites,
primarily.
You can manipulate your
Calendar, Gmail, Contacts--
lots of other services.
There's a whole long list.
And you configure scripts in
response to events on time, on
editing a spreadsheet, on the
Form submit, and so on.
But we grew up to
be a bit more.
We're also a platform for
building standalone web apps
and services.
You can build a script to be
deployed at its own URL.
It can be published directly
to the Chrome Web Store.
We launched that integration
yesterday.
And it can just be authorized
to you or to your domain.
If you don't want it to be a
public script, you can write
your own little programs that
run on the Google cloud and
our web apps, just for you, or
just your friends, or just
your domain.
So, in 2010, at Google I/O, we
launched UiApp, which is based
on the Google Web Toolkit.
It's a cross-browser
widget library
for Google Apps Script.
Easy to write, pretty easy to
understand, and the key is you
don't have too maintain
separate
client and server code.
You write one script that has
both your client parts, your
server parts, it all
gets managed.
If you've done this before, or
if you've just used Google Web
Toolkit, this will look
fairly familiar.
You create an application.
Here, we're going
to add a label.
And then, serve the app
and a little bit
of Apps Script lingo.
You always start a web app with
a function called doGet.
OK.
So this is a very basic UiApp.
In 2011, we said, well,
UiApp, sometimes it
takes a lot of code.
So let's let you draw
an interface.
We launched the GUI Builder.
It's a What You See Is
What You Get user
interface Builder for UiApp.
You can build interfaces without
writing anything.
And it's compatible with UiApp,
both in the sense that
you can embed these things
inside of a UiApp.
You can use UiApp code
to manipulate or
extend one of these.
It really was generating the
same stuff as UiApp.
So if you're following along,
probably this year, we're
going to launch something
related to user interfaces.
It seems like a good bet,
particularly because we
launched it yesterday.
So what I hear a lot from you
guys is, sometimes I just want
to write HTML.
OK.
So we're listening.
Sometimes you don't want
to write UiApp.
You want to go down to the
metal, where metal
as defined as HTML.
And just write what
you want it to be.
So I'm really excited to be
introducing HTML service.
I'm a little less excited,
because my
PM leaked it yesterday.
But I'm still very excited to
be introducing HTML service,
which is a totally new direction
for writing web apps
in Apps Script.
Rather than using our widget
library, you can write
standard HTML, JavaScript,
CSS.
You can use jQuery
and jQuery UI.
You don't have to, but
they are supported.
You can go for it.
And you have a built-in API to
run functions in the Google
Apps Script server.
So now, you can actually write
the browser application you
wanted to, directly the way you
wanted to, and still not
lose any of that awesome Google
Apps Script power,
where you can call all these
APIs, no need to go to a
dashboard, enable things.
Just start using everything in
Google, and build your app.
OK.
So let's take a quick look at
what this actually looks like.
So a few changes.
We're going to make a little
app called My HTML App--
wonder why.
And the first thing you'll
notice, it says, code dot gs.
Because we now have two
types of files--
HTML files, dot HTML, and script
files for Google Apps
Script dot gs.
Great.
So in the HTML file, we're going
to write a little bit of
HTML, just a little Hello
World example.
And I'll make a bold to prove
that it's actually HTML, which
is hard to do.
So save it.
We're going to write a little
function, the standard Apps
Script function to serve
up a web app.
So we're going to load
that file by name.
As I said before, we create
the function called doGet.
That's the entire web app.
It's going to serve
what we just made.
So manage your version.
We always have to publish
a version before
we make a web app.
I made a page.
And now we deploy.
Deploying in Google Apps
Script is always a joy.
It's a few clicks.
If it runs as you, or as a
person accessing it, you can
choose who has access to it.
I chose that it's for
me and only for me.
No one else can access it.
I get a URL, and there is,
hopefully, some HTML.
Google Apps Script can
now serve HTML.
"Hello World." OK.
[APPLAUSE]
COREY GOLDFEDER: So if I
wanted to, I could have
published this to the
Chrome Web Store.
But I suspect that there is a
lack of a need for another
"Hello World" app in the
Chrome Web Store.
So let's build something a
little more interesting with
this stuff.
And I'm going to invert
the normal
structure of these talks.
Rather than build it up
incrementally, I'm going to
show you a whole thing, and then
see what your interests
are, hopefully.
And then we'll take it apart
and see how it was built.
So let's build something
fun with Gmail.
So I'm going to play another
video for you, because I don't
trust the Wi-Fi here anymore
than you do.
So I have my email inbox.
There's a lot of
messages there.
I wish I understood
the gist of what's
going on in my inbox.
I just, at a glance, see what
people are sending me.
Luckily, I've created
a script.
So I go to script.google.com.
This script, it's about 30 lines
of Apps Script code.
You can see it uses Gmail App.
It has about 100 lines of
jQuery, jQuery UI, CSS,
JavaScript.
And we'll do a quick run
through of this at
the end of the talk.
I just want to show it to you.
It's not very big.
We're going to deploy this.
I've already deployed it-- so
it's already a version--
to get the URL And here is a tag
cloud, live off my Gmail.
I have it updating
every 30 seconds.
But I can click on a tag,
and see the threads.
They load in asynchronously,
AJAX.
I can click on a link to
the real Gmail message.
So this is a really cool
Understanding Your Gmail app
built in a tiny amount
of Apps Script.
OK.
So I'm going to do something
exceedingly foolish right now,
which is, I'm going to give you
all the URL for this app.
It's goo dot gl slash lowercase
x, capital A,
lowercase a, capital O, capital
R. Leave it up there
for a second.
And this is published so that
it runs as you, the
person using it.
So it's going to ask for
your authorization.
And the reason I'm giving it
to you this way, and not
through the Chrome Web Store,
et cetera, is this is
definitely a demo app.
It may not work.
I threw this together over
a course of two hours.
So if it breaks, I don't
want this littering
the Chrome Web Store.
So I'm going to do something
even stupider right now.
So I'm going to give you the
email address that I was
using, which is
appsscriptio@gmail.com--
appsscript, there are
two S's in there,
appsscriptio@gmail.com.
Please, over the next 20
minutes, message me.
Send anything you like with
the following caveats.
Keep it clean.
And realize that it might
show up on the
screen during my demo.
And so, it might be on the
YouTube video, et cetera.
So if you do not want
your email to be
visible, don't send it.
OK.
So I'm leaving this up
for another second.
You can try the app, yourself,
right now.
goo dot gl, lowercase x,
capital A, lowercase a,
capital O, capital R. And you
can send something to my
account, where we'll look at
my cloud at the end at
appsscriptio@gmail.com.
OK.
I hope, now, you see that you
can build really cool stuff
with Apps Script in
HTML service.
So let's take a dive
into this.
Because this is an advanced
session, and we're going to
see some code.
Use what you know.
This is our credo.
The technologies you know,
standard HTML, CSS, and
JavaScript--
optionally, jQuery
and jQuery UI.
A lot of other plug-ins
will work.
I keep stressing jQuery and
jQuery UI, because we actually
test those libraries.
And that's part of our
test suite, so we
know those will work.
But there are many other
JavaScript libraries that you
can just plug in, and it
will work with this.
And at the end of the session
we'll see why something would
or wouldn't work and what
you can expect to work.
And you still get everything
that you know an love about
Apps Script.
You get the authentication
with Google Accounts.
So you can say, only for these
people, only for this domain.
You get access to all the Apps
Script APIs that use Gmail
app, in that example.
You'll get painless
deployment.
A click or two, and your
web app is ready to go.
And you get embedding
in Google Apps.
So I didn't demo this yet.
But anywhere you could show a
UiApp in the past, you can now
show also in HTML service.
Which means you can have HTML
with jQuery embedded in sites
and embedded in spreadsheets.
You can open up a dialog
in spreadsheets, with a
full-blown web app that you
wrote, that is living inside a
spreadsheet.
So how do I call the server?
Because it's really cool that
I can generate this HTML.
It's pretty on the client.
But it's not really interesting,
unless I can make
calls back to the Google
Apps Script server
and make it do things.
OK.
So introducing--
this, I'm really excited about--
the google.script API.
And this is a real big change
for us, because this is the
first time Apps Script is
launching a client-side API.
This does not live
on our servers.
This is going to live
in your browser.
And you can call our servers
with this and run scripts.
So you could make these calls
through the app script server
from your client code.
You not to worry about
AJAX and XHR.
And if you don't know what
those words are, great,
because you have to
worry about them.
We're going to do all
that for you.
You're going to make a function
call on the client.
Magically, it will happen
on the server.
And the response
will come back.
And that's all you are going
to have to know about.
So here's a basic example.
I write a function on the server
called doSomething,
which logs that it, in
fact, did something.
And then I'm going to write a
function on the client, in my
browser code.
So inside a  tag,
google.script.run.doSomething.
And that's going to call the
function on the server.
I just want to point out, right
now, the structure of
the slides.
Because this is going to be the
rest of the presentation.
On the top, I have some Google
Apps Script code, that's
server code.
That would be in
a code.gs file.
On the bottom, I have some
HTML and JavaScript code.
That would be in an HTML file.
And since we're going to be
talking about the interaction
of these two files, virtually
every slide will have some
Google Apps Script code
and some HTML code.
So you can do more than
just call a function.
You can pass information from
the client to the server.
Here, I have a function,
getSubject, which in our Gmail
app might have been
useful to get the
subject of the message.
On the client, I can call it
with a string, "a gmail thread
id." Hopefully, it would be
an actual Gmail thread ID.
And on the server, I will
have that parameter.
Now it's not just strings.
You could pass Booleans,
numbers, arrays, objects.
Basically, anything that can
be converted to JSON
you can send up.
And you don't actually have
to do the conversion.
You don't have to stringify
it and unstringify.
We will do that for you.
So you can just add a send any
object up, and it will get
copied to the server.
I'm not going to show here,
because it's a little bit too
deep, even for this session.
But you can even send up files
through a file upload.
So you can send up
an entire files.
They get uploaded to the
server in an Ajaxy way.
You can use them, save them to
your drive, save them to a
site, email them, and
return a response.
And that's really cool.
It's in the user guide, which
was updated today as well.
You can return a value
from your functions.
So here, I've filled in the top
function, no longer a comment.
GmailApp.
We're going to getThreads
for that threadId.
And The First Message
is Subject.
See, that's the subject that
gets shown in Gmail in the
user interface.
So I'm returning it.
But how does it get handled
in the client?
Because if you guys know
anything about JavaScript,
JavaScript is single threaded
on the client.
Which means that if we waited
for the server to respond with
the answer, your entire browser
would freeze while
that was going on.
That's not a good idea.
So what happens is when you
make a function call, in
google.script, it's
asynchronous.
So the function gets called
to the server.
And then your code continues
where it was.
You can specify a Handler,
a Success Handler.
Here's what I've done here.
I specified a Success Handler
called myHandler.
And when the server is finished,
if it returned a
value, it will call your Handler
with that value.
And here's an example
of a Handler.
So this Handler would just
alert, pop up a browser
message box saying, "The subject
was," and the subject
of this thread.
But this is actually a full
use case of google.script.
I have a function I'm calling
on the server.
It returns a value.
So we get the full round trip.
And it gets handled by a
function on the client.
Now, you can do more than
that if your server
function throws an error.
So here I'm using x.y
X doesn't exist.
Y doesn't exist.
Easiest way I know, in three
characters, to produce a
Reference Error in JavaScript.
So that's going to
cause a problem.
And on the client side, I can
add a FailureHandler, which
will get an error object
with the same
message from the server.
So we'll get that Reference
Error on the client, and they
can do something with it.
You can mix and match
SuccessHandler,
FailureHandler.
Handler.
There are other options
as well.
And you can look, again, in our
user guide for a deeper
dive on the things you can
do these functions.
But it's really straightforward.
So I just want to go through
this really clearly.
google.script.run--
you can add Success and
FailureHandlers--
dot function name
in your script.
Whatever function names
are in your script
exist on the client.
You can just call them, as if
they were client functions.
OK.
Now, sometimes I hear,
that's cool.
I can create web pages.
I can call back.
But I want to create
dynamic HTML.
I want my page to actually
have content in it that's
driven by the script.
And we've got your back.
So introducing Google Apps
Script Templates.
And this I'm more than
super excited about.
This is, I think the most
exciting thing for me today.
Google Apps Script Templates--
I want a HTML page, let's say,
with data from a spreadsheet.
And I could generate it in
code, but that's a pain.
So what I'm going to
do, again, is use
a templating language.
If you have used PHP, ASP,
JSP, embedded JavaScript,
there's a Wikipedia page that
lists all of these.
I think there's 200 of them.
Anything with scriptlet tags--
this is going to look really
familiar to you.
You can mix and match JavaScript
directly into your
HTML with the very
industry-standard
scriptlet-style tag.
So you do a tag that opens
with a question mark.
And closes with a
question mark.
And in between, is JavaScript.
And that JavaScript is going to
manipulate the HTML inside.
So if you have a for loop, the
HTML inside that loop will be
output every time in that for
loop, just like PHP, or ASP,
or JSP, or everything
like that.
A little grace note.
You may notice that I've
italicized the code that's
inside the scriptlet tags.
Because on the Google Apps
Script editor, you'll
actually see that.
So we italicize code that gets
thrown on the server.
And we don't italicize
client-side scripts.
So you can, at a glance, tell
which parts of your app are
running on the server and
dynamically generating stuff,
and which parts of your app
are running on the client.
So I think that's pretty cool.
I think it's cool enough
to actually do a demo.
Beforehand, I just want to go
through the three things you
need to know about Google
Apps Script Templates.
First is a scriptlet tag.
We call it a standard
scriptlet.
That's the question mark
question mark tag.
And that just adds code.
So if you want to add for loop
around some HTML, that's the
way you do it.
The second one should be
very familiar also.
It's the question
mark equals tag.
We call that a printing
scriptlet, because it runs
some code and also prints out
a value into the stream.
So this is the easiest way to
get a value from your server
code into your dynamically
created page.
And finally, there's a force
printing scriptlet, which does
something about escaping.
And I'm going to not
explain that now.
Let's show you the demo.
And then after the demo, it
should be a little easier to
explain what a force printing
scriptlet is.
So let's play this.
I have a spreadsheet.
And in the spreadsheet, I have
the things I like and don't
like about various
days of the week.
For example, Friday.
I like the fact that it's
before Saturday.
I don't like the fact that
it's after Thursday.
Here's a really simple
function.
I'm going to zoom
in a little bit.
I use HTMLService.
I'm going to create a template
from a file.
I'm using a SpreadsheetApp to
get the active spreadsheet to
get the data, stuffing
that onto a
variable on the template.
In the template, it's the same
code I just showed you.
I just added a little bit of
styles around it, some CSS,
some class names in the
style sheet up top.
But that's selected
as the same code
that was in my slide.
So this is just for loop.
And if we run this function,
it's actually going to show
this is a dialog in
the spreadsheet.
So there is the exact same data
in the spreadsheet as in
HTML dialog in the
spreadsheet.
And again, I could've done
jQuery, AJAX stuff, calls to
other servers, anything
I wanted to there.
Let me show you how
templates work.
So here, I'm logging a function
called t.getCode,
template get code.
I look at the logs,
in a second.
If I look at the logs, I'm
going to see this mess of
JavaScript.
And here's a really
cool feature of
Google Apps Script Templates.
We actually generate
intermediate JavaScript that
you can debug.
And we show it to you.
So you can, at any point, get
the code, see what it is, look
for bugs, fix them, if you want,
or go back to template
and fix them.
And you can really debug what's
actually going on.
If you would like a different
view of it, there's actually a
different function, which
we'll see in a second--
getCodeWithComments, which
is also a debug function.
It's going to give you the same
code we saw, just, this
time, with an interesting
set of comments.
Let me just Copy, Paste it out,
because it's hard to see
in the logger.
So every line of the original
template is a comment to the
corresponding line
in the script.
So you can easily find
where your bugs are.
If you have a mistake, this
is a line preserving
transformation.
So you can actually see,
here's my bug.
Here it is in the script.
Let me go to the template
and fix it.
And this is the fastest way I
know to debug a template.
Much easier than grepping around
the template, trying to
figure out what happened.
Because this is line
transforming, the code that
you generate actually has
some cool properties.
If I add that same reference
error here--
so throw an error.
Let's notice it's on line six.
OK.
We've noticed.
I run the function.
I should get an error.
And, in fact, the error
is on line six.
Because the intermediate code
we generate is line
preserving.
So rather than hide this behind
a layer and not let you
see what's going on,
we want you see
exactly what's happening.
This is a JavaScript
transformation.
And you can see it.
And you can work with it and
make it work for you.
OK.
So what was that stuff about
escaping and force printing?
We have two types of
printing scriptlets
in Apps Script Templates.
We have the regular printing
scriptlet, which makes sure
you don't do a common mistake
that can really bite you in a
web app, which is, it doesn't
let you accidentally inject
JavaScript or HTML.
If you use a printing scriptlet,
and you have, let's
say, some HTML or script markup,
it will actually
contextually turn it
into a string.
If you're inside JavaScript,
it will become
a JavaScript string.
If you're inside an HTML
attribute, you will correctly
escape with HTML entities.
Wherever you are, it will
say, no problem.
I will make this
appear as text.
If you use a forced printing
scriptlet, you know what
you're doing.
And it's going to print
exactly what you
said into the stream.
So here's the difference.
I have a little template
on top.
I have a string with a script.
The script does a
very bad thing.
It says so.
And I have two forced printing
scriptlets that are going to
both print out the same
exact string.
I'm sorry, two printing
scriptlets.
One is a printing one, and one
is a forced printing one.
Here's the output.
The printing one actually
prints in the
text of that script.
So you can't make a mistake.
You can't have an XSS attack.
You can't have someone injecting
JavaScript or HTML
that you didn't expect, or
styles into your code.
The forced printing one looks
like it did nothing.
But actually, it printed a
script tag, which is not
visible and is doing
the very bad thing.
So as a rule of thumb, use the
printing scriptlets, which are
the standard-looking
scriptlets--
the ones that look like
every other language.
And only use the force printing
scriptlets when you
know what you're doing.
And you know exactly where your
data comes from, and you
trust that it doesn't have
anything nasty embedded in it.
So let me recap HTMLService.
Use HTMLService to serve
HTML and JavaScript.
Call back to the server with
google.script, with our new
client-side API.
And generate dynamic
content with
Google Apps Script Templates.
I think, together, this is a
really powerful set of tools
for building web apps with Apps
Script, in a way that you
couldn't do before.
HTMLServices does have some
limitations, because it runs
on the script.google.com domain,
which means that we're
serving it on google.com.
And we have to make sure
that certain dangerous
things can't happen.
The first thing that HTMLService
limits you to is
ECMAScript 5, ES5, strict mode,
which is the newest
version of JavaScript.
Now, even on a browser doesn't
support ES5 strict mode,
HTMLService rewrites your code
to emulate ES5 strict mode.
In practice, that means
you don't get with.
You don't get a val.
You don't get arguements.callee.
You should rarely notice the
difference between ECMAScript
3, which is the current
standard, and ECMAScript 5.
It's hard to tell.
Scripts can't access cookies
or other browser resources.
You can navigate the history.
You can't get cookies.
These are security provisions to
make sure that you can't do
things that the user
didn't expect.
And at some point, while we may
look into opening some of
these up, at the moment, this
is the state of the world.
And finally, scripts can't
dynamically install new scripts.
You can't get around our sandbox
by writing a script
tag into the DOM and loading
in something
from somewhere else.
I think that last one,
actually, is
worthy of its own slide.
Because it's probably the one
place it's easy to get tripped
in HTMLService, is
this restriction.
So like I said, first, you can't
dynamically add a new
script tag.
That's the obvious place where
this restriction shows up.
The less obvious
place is this.
This will work.
I write a new button into
the DOM, just a text.
And I associate a function
with that button.
It's a ClickHandler.
That is totally fine,
and that will work.
This, which is a common pattern,
will not work.
I write a function with
an onClick handler
and write in as text.
And the reason that won't work
is that, to our sandbox, that
looks like a brand new script
that we have no
idea what it is.
We've never seen it before.
And we can't properly
guarantee that we
can sanitize it.
Now, the good news is we
actually think we do know how
to do this.
And we're looking forward to
lifting all these restrictions
in the near term.
But for the moment, what we're
launching is you cannot
dynamically install new scripts,
either via script tag
or via this method.
Now, it's not just about
limitations.
HTMLService also gives you some
awesome new stuff that
you wouldn't get with just
plain old JavaScript.
First of all, we emulate
ECMAScript 5 strict mode
everywhere.
Which means that regardless of
what browser you're actually
running on, you know what
version of JavaScript is
actually running.
It will always be the same.
We fill in missing
modern JavaScript
functions on all browsers.
If you've used array.map,
function.bind, object.keys,
these really super useful
functions that exists in
modern browsers, well, now
they're available in every
browser, not just Firefox,
Chrome, Safari, and Opera.
So you can use all these
modern functions on any
browser you like.
You can use jQuery and jQuery
UI, even embedded in a
spreadsheet.
This is really awesome.
Inside that spreadsheet
dialog that I showed
you, you can do anything.
And the reason is we
trust our sandbox.
And so, whatever you're doing
in there, go wild.
If you could do it in a web app,
you can do it inside a
spreadsheet.
Now, Google Caja, which is the
underlying technology here, is
open source.
You can get to it as
developers.google.com/caja.
This is cool, because if
you see a feature or a
bug, help us fix it.
This is an open source project
with really, really active
development.
And we are using the latest
version of it, as soon as it
gets pushed.
So you can join in with us, and
make this service better.
So I have a few minutes left.
And I feel like I have
enough time to launch
one more major service.
And I'm really excited, because
this is the first
thing I'm launching that my
PM has not yet leaked.
Sometimes I hear
from you guys.
I don't want to return HTML.
I just want to return JSON,
or RSS, or XML, or
something like that.
Well, we heard you
say that too.
So introducing ContentService,
the twin of HTMLService for
everything that is not HTML.
You can return text
from a script.
And by text, I mean you can
return JSON, RSS, XML, Atom.
Whatever it is you're writing
for a service, you can return
it from a script.
This is perfect for writing
things that will be consumed
by other programs.
So if you're writing something
for consumption by an RSS
reader, like Google Reader, or
something for consumption by
another API, or another web
service that you want to be
able to hit your script
and do something.
If you're writing something so
that an App Engine program
could call your script, and
get back a JSON response,
using your script as an
API, this is for you.
And no Caja or UiApp
sanitization applied.
Whatever you told us to return,
this is what we return.
The way we do that, if you look
in our user docs, you'll
see the tricks we have to
do to make that safe.
But as far as you're concerned,
you return text.
You say, I'd like to
serve this text.
We serve that text.
And you can use it
in services.
This is the entire API.
I would love to complicate
it, make it sound
complicated and cool.
But no, you do ContentService
, createTextOutput, put the
content you want in.
And then you can optionally
set a MimeType.
You don't even have
It defaults to PLAIN_TEXT.
You return that from a script,
from a doGet function.
You have an API or a service.
That is all there is to it.
In fact, I'm not even going to
show you the "Hello World"
demo, because this would
be the entire thing.
And it would show "Hello World."
So let's go with a
slightly more interesting
demo.
That email address,
appsscriptio@gmail.com, which
you have been assiduously
emailing things to, I hope.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
COREY GOLDFEDER: We'll
talk about that.
Well, that email address that
I had prerecorded a video
from, I would like to see it
not just as a tag cloud.
But I'd actually like
to see a version of
this as an RSS feed.
Let's see how easy
that is to do.
I claim I can do this in 4 lines
of Apps Script code and
15 lines of HTML.
So I'm using ContentService.c
reateTextOutput.
I'm using HTMLServices
Templates.
I'm not actually serving HTML.
I'm just using the template
structure to build an RSS
feed, because XML, HTML,
it's all the same.
I use GmailApp.getInboxThreads.
I'm calling it from inside
the template.
That will work.
Why not?
I loop through the threads.
For each thread, I created
an RSS item.
It's pretty straightforward.
And then I'm going to publish
this as a script
and see what happens.
I have to authorize
it, of course.
You have to authorize this, so
that it can use your Gmail.
Our new deployment.
And I'm going to deploy this.
Be careful.
I have to deploy this so that
it's visible to anyone,
including Anonymous, because
Google Reader
visits URLs as Anonymous.
It has no credentials when
it visits a URL.
So it's crucial that if I want
this be read by a RSS reader,
that anyone has to be
able to hit it.
In practice, that means that
anyone could to read this
feed, if they had the URL.
And so it's not a great idea
to put something private in
that feed, unless you're very
careful about not giving
anyone that URL.
OK.
Here's the big red
Subscribe button.
I'm going to drop in that URL.
I want to be clear.
This is the URL of
a script that I'm
treating as an RSS feed.
Click Add.
And here we go.
There is my email
as an RSS feed.
Fifteen lines of HTML
Templates, four
lines of Apps Script.
Tell me how hard this would be
to do on any other platform.
[APPLAUSE]
COREY GOLDFEDER: So I want to
just emphasize, you can do a
lot more with this than just
turn Gmail into RSS, which is,
itself, kind of awesome.
You can filter RSS feeds.
There's a great Google
FeedFetcher API that can fetch
any RSS feed in any format.
It gives you a standard
JSON output.
And you can build feeds
out of that.
So you can build filtered
versions of
your favorite feeds.
You can pull in two feeds
together, and output a
combined feed.
You can take one feed in, and
output two URLs that have
different parts of the feed.
You can do anything you want.
And that's just with RSS.
You can build APIs that
return JSON, XML.
Like I said, anything
that's text, build
it with this stuff.
So that raises an important
question.
What should I use?
I have UiApp.
I have a ContentService.
I have HTMLService.
Which one do I use when?
And the answer is, it depends
on what you want.
All of our output types
complement each
other pretty well.
Use UiApp, if you're building
a simple, cross-browser
compatible UI.
You don't want to deal
with writing client
code and server code.
You want to show a few buttons,
some text, have some
interaction, maybe some AJAX.
But the basic idea here is you
want it to be simple code.
And you don't want to have to
deal separately with the HTML.
HTMLService to build complex
AJAX web apps.
You want to write down to the
metal, and make something that
screams, make something that's
exactly what you wanted,
HTMLService is for you.
You can write exactly what you
wanted and still call back
into Google script
anytime you want.
And use ContentService to build
services and RSS feeds,
things that are consumed
not by user,
but by another program.
Pretty straightforward.
I think it's easy to choose,
depending on your result, what
you want to do.
Remember, the same script can
actually serve all three.
You can have a parameter and
the URL at the end, and so
have the same script serving an
RSS view of something and
an HTML view, depending on the
URL parameters you put in.
So let me just wrap up all the
things that Google Apps Script
has launched this week, because
I just want to point
out how awesome this is.
We have really changed
the product.
And I think it's much more
powerful today than it was a
few days ago.
We launched standalone scripts
that aren't tied to
spreadsheets.
They live at script.google.com.
Or you can go to Google Drive,
click the Create More menu,
and see scripts right
there in your drive.
We launched scripts that run
with the authority of the
user, not the script author.
So it runs not as
me, but as you.
When you run it, you get to
authorize it yourself.
The ScriptDB store, a database
for building scripts that need
a database.
A JSON-based NoSQL store.
And there's a talk on this in
Room 7 at 5:15, by Drew.
And I really encourage you
to go do it, because
you'll learn a lot.
Direct Chrome Web Store
integration.
Again, we launched
that yesterday.
A few clicks, and your app is
packaged up, ready to go into
Chrome Web Store.
All you need to do is add a
description and an icon.
HTMLService and Templates are
building dynamic web apps.
If you don't know what that is,
you have been asleep for
40 minutes, and shame on you.
ContentService for building
services and feeds.
That is a lot of stuff.
I just want to run through the
code of Gmail tags one time,
because I promised this
at the beginning.
And I didn't really
deliver on that.
So I'm not going
to go through--
before everyone starts
glazing over--
all the code.
I just want to demonstrate the
fact that the things that we
talked about today are what's
inside of this.
There's a doGet function.
It's creating a template
from a file, just
like we talked about.
There's a function
getThreadBody.
It's just like the getSubject
function.
It takes an id and returns
the body of a thread.
This one is a little
more complicated.
It gets the tag cloud.
It does a lot of analytics about
what's the common words
in your Gmail.
But it's purely Apps Script.
There's nothing new about it.
It's just a little bit
of App Script.
Here we're using, on the
client, in the HTML,
jQuery, jQuery UI.
We have a server variable,
getGmailTags.
And here's something
really cool.
We can pass server variable to
the client, by writing it
right into the HTML.
So here we are with our tags in
the client equals tags from
the server.
And that data is now baked into
the HTML that we serve.
That's some jQuery
and jQuery UI.
I think we'll just
skip over that.
Look on jQuery's website to
learn how to do that stuff.
Here we have a google.script.run
with a
SuccessHandler.
I inlined the SuccessHandler,
so it looks a little
complicated.
But at the bottom, down there,
you can see it's
google.script.run,
getGmailTags.
Same function from the server.
Once we're calling it at the
top, and once we're calling in
the middle.
And this is actually refreshing
every 30 seconds.
Here's a lot of styles.
We'll skip over those.
They're just regular styles.
And
At the bottom, here's
a little template.
Because the first time we load
the page, we don't want to
make AJAX call and have to
get the clouds that way.
So the first time we load the
page, we write the cloud
directly in with the template.
And after that, every time
afterwards, we refresh it.
OK.
That is actually
the entire app.
And it's really not
that complicated.
88 lines of HTML and JavaScript,
a little bit of
Google App Script.
So let me do this.
Mine is working.
So here is my version of the
app, coming off of my page.
And I actually have no idea
what's here, because this is
different from what I showed
you in the video.
Because people have
emailed things.
So I'm going to click the very
large JavaScript word and see
what threads have to
do with JavaScript.
Loading from the server.
"Webapps are hard, let's go
scripting." So there we go.
The law of demos
did not apply.
All I want is a bit of HTML, a
side of JavaScript and data
centers for as far as
the eye can see.
I have weird friends.
OK.
So one more thing to show
you in this demo.
There's a little
Uglify button.
It's, unfortunately,
offscreen.
It says Uglify.
I'm going to click it.
It will make things ugly.
And the reason for doing that is
I want to demonstrate this
is real client code.
That's actually a fairly
interesting thing that's very
hard to do with UiApp and
trivial to do with
HTMLService.
And I just want to demonstrate
that this is straight up
client code.
I'm writing style sheets in.
I just flipped the style name
on one top-level item.
And that flipped everything
over, and I can go right back
to prettified.
Moral of the story.
Go away, or I will replace
you with a very
small Google Apps Script.
There's so much that Google
Apps Script can do with so
little code.
And I think that's the
coolest thing.
You go to script.google.com.
You type a few lines of code.
You click a menu or two,
and there is your app.
That's it.
There's no deploying.
There's no making JARs.
There's no XML configuration.
You don't even need
a separate ID.
On any web computer, you go
to script.google.com.
You type in the logic, just
the logic of what you're
trying to do--
none of the boilerplate,
just the logic of what
you wanted to do.
And there you are.
There's your web app.
OK.
So I'm printing Thank You.
Not force printing, because I
don't know who that came from.
And I just want to point out,
before we take any questions,
that you can join the Google
Apps Script community on
stackoverflow.com.
We have an active community of
questions, answers-- both from
the team and from external
developers, like yourselves.
Thank you very much.
And any questions?
[APPLAUSE]
COREY GOLDFEDER: I just want to
say, if there is anyone who
does have a question, if you can
come to the microphones in
the middle, so that they'll show
up on the YouTube video.
And we can hear them.
AUDIENCE: So, my question is,
what we would be the URL of
this app that you showed us?
COREY GOLDFEDER: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: What is the
URL of this app?
COREY GOLDFEDER: I can get
back to it afterwards.
I actually don't remember it
off the top of my head.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But can you control what's
the URL of the--
COREY GOLDFEDER: So, the URL
that comes from the script is
tied to the script.
But of course, you can alias
it any way you like.
You can make any URL redirect
to that URL,
so that will work.
AUDIENCE: And can you deploy
some extra resources, like
CSSice or images?
COREY GOLDFEDER: Yes.
You can link in external
CSS resources, external
JavaScript.
Anything you link in gets
linked in on the server.
So even though it looks like
a link on the client, we
actually link it in on the
server, parse it out and
sanitize it right there.
AUDIENCE: But you have to host
it from another server, yeah?
COREY GOLDFEDER: OK.
So you can do two things.
You can host it from another
server, if you want to.
That's where I got the jQuery
library from and the CSS that
I was using.
You can also have
an HTML file.
It's not a CSS file, but you
can have a style tag in it,
and just inline it
directly in.
You can build Apps Script
libraries that have all kinds
of client code in them.
And instead of doing link
source equals, you
just inline them in.
In practice, there's no
difference, because we are
going to inline any external
resources anyways, the way
that we do the sanitization.
So there's no performance
difference between inlining
and linking an external
resource.
AUDIENCE: And images I have
to host outside of the--
COREY GOLDFEDER: Images.
So I didn't mention something.
Images, we proxy them through
Google image proxy.
So they have to be
publicly visible.
But aside from that, they
can be anywhere.
So anywhere you could use an
image with UiApp before you
can use now.
We do not have integrated image
hosting for Google Apps
Script at the moment.
AUDIENCE: It looks like I can
use it for most of the apps I
will be writing.
So what I shouldn't
use it for?
What are the use cases
I shouldn't use them?
COREY GOLDFEDER: I think this
is really great when you're
trying to build something that's
about Google Apps.
Where what are trying to build
requires deep integration or
fast integration with
Google Apps.
Because you have all
these APIs, right?
They're baked right in.
You can see that it's a single
line of code to get my inbox
spreads from Gmail.
Everything is like that.
All the APIs are like that.
So if you're writing an app
that's about Google, about
your account or the user's
account, this is a really
great tool.
If you're trying to build a
service that has nothing to do
with Google, some of the
limitations we're putting on
you are going to be limiting
unnecessarily.
The rewriting of HTML,
et cetera.
You won't need those things,
because you're not using any
Google features anyways.
So for those cases, Google, as
a company, has a lot of ways
that you can build apps.
But if you're trying to do tight
integration with apps
and particularly we're trying to
do extensions to Apps, this
is the only way to write
extensions to apps.
So if you're trying to do
anything with tight
integration to apps,
I really encourage
you to use Apps Script.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
This is great.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned pictures
must be [INAUDIBLE]
publicly.
So I cannot take any images
from my Google Drive?
COREY GOLDFEDER: If there's a
publicly visible URL for that
image, I believe you can
set that in Drive.
Although I could be wrong.
I believe there's a way
to set a publicly--
AUDIENCE: But only
if it's public?
COREY GOLDFEDER: It
has to be public.
This is, actually, a security
restriction for very
interesting reasons.
There's a lot of dangerous
things you can do with images,
shockingly dangerous code that
an image can cost to execute.
All we do is make sure that
that image that you load
doesn't have any of those
things in it.
And we need to be able
to load that on the
server, not on the client.
Because on the client,
it's too late.
Once we've loaded that image,
we can detect that something
bad happened.
AUDIENCE: But if it's already
on Google Drive, you have
access to it.
COREY GOLDFEDER: That
is a good point.
And in the future, we probably
should look into an
integration where we can serve
directly from Drive.
AUDIENCE: --or from
the Picasa.
COREY GOLDFEDER: And
I see that my
team members are nodding.
This is something we
have talked about.
At the moment, we do not treat
pictures from Google any
different than any
other pictures.
But that is definitely something
that is certainly
something we've thought about
and should think about.
AUDIENCE: What about PDF?
COREY GOLDFEDER: Actually,
I don't know.
I think PDFs will work.
We should find out.
AUDIENCE: I mean,
private PDFs?
COREY GOLDFEDER: There's
no difference.
Anything you're showing on an
image tag is going to have to
go through the public path.
AUDIENCE: OK.
COREY GOLDFEDER: But you
can link to things.
Because you can link to things,
and load them in the
page, et cetera.
Are there any other questions?
There are two microphones.
Going once, going twice.
Well, thank you very much.
And I hope that you
enjoy working
with Google Apps Script.